do you like that Bureau
[Music]
you're going skydiving together who's
more nervous I think I probably would
say I'm more nervous but I don't really
feel nervous don't know I'm just nervous
that I might pee my pants a little bit I
feel like I wanted like a glass of
champagne to chill me out a little bit
but oh I wouldn't really make this a
little more excited I did ask if
anyone's peed their pants when they've
jumped oh yeah how do I look
profesh are you more nervous now or
ahead of your finale Oh Garrett
oh I had in the finale for sure this is
a piece of cake compared to that also
hold your harness right here body's more
before this I feel locked and loaded all
right guys we are walking to the plane
for you to jump how you feeling super
excited ready to do it what's more
stressful moving in together or jumping
out of a plane moving in together yeah
I'm still falling for you oh wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
are you worried about her at all yes I
was yeah I do not pee my pants that's
good you've moved in together
you've skydived what is next
done maybe about nothing could be this
low I know this one's name this is the
man oh yeah
[Music]